bonsoir à tous
alors vous voyez je suis pas venu les
mains vides
j'ai ramené mon carnet ça doit vous
paraître assez classique comme carnet vu
d'ici mais pour moi c'est un carnet très
important je crois même que si je devais
partir sur une île déserte
ce serait une des rares choses que
j'emporterais avec moi alors vous voyez
une bonne histoire ça commence par un
mystère par une promesse qu'est ce qu'il
ya de si important dans ce carnet
pourquoi est ce que j'y tiens temps
alors bien entendu je vais pas vous
répondre tout de suite mais on y
reviendra
je laisse ici quelques instants pourquoi
est ce qu'on croit aux histoires
pourquoi est-ce qu'on aime la fiction et
puis d'abord c'est quoi une bonne
histoire
on peut dire une bonne histoire c'est
des rebondissements du suspense il ya
une part de ça c'est vrai mais je pense
que c'est un peu plus encore une bonne
histoire c'est une histoire qu'on
cherche une autre vision du monde
quand on lit un livre on s'évade on est
prêt à prendre l'identité de quelqu'un
d'autre
on peut sympathiser avec des criminels
des mafieux des gens qui ont des
expériences des vies des valeurs
complètement opposées aux nôtres ce
qu'on fait pas dans la vraie vie
donc la lecture nous met sur une forme
d'hypnose
mais une hypnose vont serait beaucoup
plus ouvert d'esprit on serait prêt à
remettre en cause nos certitudes et
depuis que j'ai écrit j'ai découvert ce
pouvoir de la fiction est ma conviction
c'est que si on défend des nos idées pas
même manière qu'on raconte une histoire
on serait beaucoup mieux compris parce
que alors l'aller les autres seraient
prêts à faire un pas vers nous ils
seraient prêts à rentrer dans notre
univers est à oublier leurs préjugés
donc comment est ce qu'on fait rentrer
les gens dans notre univers comment est
ce qu'on raconte une bonne histoire
alors j'ai pas la recette magique
j'aimerais bien mais je n'ai pas encore
trouvé mais à force d'écrire g j'ai
découvert qu'elle
piste et j'ai envie de les partager avec
vous donc on va passer de l'autre côté
du miroir
du côté où on crée elle réussit d'abord
il faut faire naître des images des
images qui vont évoquer quelque chose
par exemple si on a envie de décrire une
grande ville si on veut décrire new york
à quelqu'un quelqu'un qui n'auraient
jamais entendu parler de new york
on peut dire new york c'est une ville de
9 millions d'habitants avec énormément
de gratte ciel c'est correct mais est ce
que c'est vraiment évocateur en revanche
si je vous dis new york c'est une ville
de bouffe une ville debout alors c'est
une citation de voyage au bout de la
nuit
le roman a été écrit dans les années 30
et à l'époque le personnage principal
qui arrive à manhattan découvre pour la
première fois il gratte ciel mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'avec ce mot
debout à mots tout simples même pas un
objectif d'ailleurs c'est même pas une
phrase correcte mais avec ce mot on a
une image
tout à coup on est ce migrants qui
arrivent dans les années trente à
manhattan et qui découvre une ville à la
verticale autre exemple on veut décrire
l'horreur de la guerre
ça arrive souvent dans les romans on
peut dire c'était un massacre
épouvantable
les soldats étaient étendus mort sur le
champ de bataille
alors ça marche aussi mais vous voyez on
utilise des mots très forts mais est ce
que est ce que ça évoque quelque chose
est ce que le mot a du sens c'est ce que
le mois du poids en revanche si on dit
comme le dit rabot il a deux trous
rouges au côté droit
c'est une image beaucoup plus simple
c'est ce qu'un enfant dirait en
découvrant la scène mais on l'appareil
on a une image on ressent l'horreur de
la guerre alors ce que je veux vous dire
c'est bien entendu on a peut devenir des
rabots du jour au lendemain on va pas
devenir céline mais on peut tous à notre
niveau
revenir à ces images
communiquer de façon plus simple de
façon essayé de transmettre nos émotions
par ces images on peut aussi le faire
avec des objets c'est surtout dans les
films dans l'est dans les films
d'espionnage on est à la recherche du
micro film ultra secret et on est
poursuivi par tous les gouvernements
pour ce microfilms dans les films de
gangsters on est à la recherche des
lingots d'or qui sont planqués tout au
fond du coffre de la banque
c'est ce que hitchcock appelle un mcdo
fine un mec de fine c'est l'objet qui va
lancer l'action d'un film mais pour moi
l'objet il a une autre valeur en fait
l'objet c'est une porte d'entrée dans un
récit je vous expliquais imaginons que
je vais vous raconter une histoire
d'amour histoire d'amour on a déjà vu ça
un milliard de fois dans les films dans
les livres comment arriver à rendre
aussi évocateur maintenant imaginons que
mon personnage principal par exemple de
temps en temps il ouvre son tiroir et
ils découvrent un courrier un courrier
de son amour de jeunesse
et dès qu'il retrouve ce courrier il a
les larmes qui lui montent aux yeux
à partir de là en fait le courrier va
symboliser l'amour de jeunesse
et quand on va en reparler ce sentiment
abstrait il va être tangible quand dès
que le personnage va ressortir le
courrier vous serez que c'est que ça
correspond à l'amour de jeunesse et
mieux encore je pense si l'histoire est
bien racontée en fait ce qui va se
passer c'est que quand le personnage va
ouvrir son tiroir et ressortir le
courrier vous allez y mettre votre
propre émotion
vous allez repenser à votre propre amour
de jeunesse vous allez avoir votre
propre texte sur ce courrier donc
l'objet devient une sorte de talisman
qui vous permet d'entrer dans le récit
et j'en arrive au point le plus
important pour moi c'est une bonne
histoire
c'est une histoire où vous avez un grand
rôle
par exemple quand vous allez au cinéma
quand vous allez voir un film
d'épouvanté
bien sûr vous sursautez contre le
fantôme arrive sur l'écran mais je crois
que vous avez encore plus peur avant
vous avez peur quand il ne sait encore
rien passé quand
les héros se promène dans une maison
vide et que vous vous doutez qui va
arriver quelque chose
et dès lors vous faites le scénario et à
partir de là en fait la personne qui
écoute a beaucoup plus de le suggérer à
beaucoup plus de force
d'ailleurs stephen king disait ce qui
fait peur dans un livre c'est pas le
fantôme derrière l'escalier c'est
l'escalier et en fait quand j'étais
petit je pensais qu'être un grand auteur
s'était écrire un roman de 1000 pages
très gros roman où je maîtriserai tout
et c'est au fur et à mesure que je me
suis rendu compte que c'était un peu
linverse en fait on commet tous cette
erreur dans la vraie vie quand on a une
idée qui nous tient à coeur quand on a
une émotion parfois on a tellement envie
de convaincre l'autre on a tellement
envie de de le persuader qu'on va lui
sortir plein d'arguments on va
l'accabler
est ce qui va se passer c'est que la
personne va se refermer
elle va refuser de d'accepter votre
point de vue elle va se refermer sur ses
préjugés alors que moi je pense qu'il
faut parier sur l'intelligence des gens
il faut leur donner les clés de notre
univers et après on a une chance en
faisant ça que la personne soit
convaincue elle se dit ça ça me parle ça
ça m'évoque quelque chose alors
maintenant je pourrais vous laisser
puisque j'ai dit que l'auteur n'avait
qu'un rôle secondaire
mais avant de partir ben je vais
reprendre mon carnet pas bien sûr je
pourrais vous dire ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur mais je pense que ça
briserait un peu le mystère
parce que finalement peut-être que vous
y avez déjà mis un peu de vous dans ce
carnet vous avez peut-être déjà pensé à
votre à l'objet que vous emporteriez sur
une île déserte
donc finalement si je disais ce que j'ai
mis à l'intérieur vous soyez forcément
déçu et pour finir j'aimerais parler du
petit prince à l'extrait que vous
connaissez sans doute tous le fameux
dessine moi un mouton mais je ne sais
pas si vous connaissez vraiment le texte
derrière
en fait le petit prince demande à
l'aviateur de lui dessiner un mouton
l'aviateur en dessine un premier est
petit prince lui dit non celui-là est
trop vieux fait branle un autre
l'aviateur dessine un deuxième bouton le
petit prince udine dont celui et des
cornes
donc c'est pas un mouton par l'aviateur
sûr mais un troisième dessin un peu
énervé puisqu'il est dans le désert en
train de réparer son avion autre chose à
faire que de dessiner des boutons mais
leur dessiner un troisième est le petit
prince lui dit non celui-là est trop
faible
il tiendra pas longtemps alors pour
finir l'aviateur y dessine une boîte et
lui fait c'est la boîte le mouton que tu
veux est à l'intérieur et le petit
prince répond c'est le plus beau mouton
que j'aurais pu imaginer
donc si je vais vous faire retenir une
chose c'est que raconter une bonne
histoire ça n'est pas dessiner le plus
beau mouton possible c'était la boîte et
après l'essai la personne en face de
nous en faire ce qu'elle veut voilà donc
je pense que je vais vous laisser le
mystère sur ce carnet puisque il vous
appartient peut à présent
merci
[Applaudissements]